the left is very very upset about
privilege these days specifically
they say white privilege and when you
look into the
specific examples they give of white
privilege doesn't seem to be
very convincing but there is a privilege
going around and it's a privilege that
the left does not want to destroy
they're doing everything they can to
maintain it i think
a perfect example of this came from
hillary clinton the other day
or i'm not sorry not hillary clinton
hillary clinton's daughter who for some
reason
is in public life she has famous parents
and so now for some reason
she's in public life chelsea clinton was
on a
women for biden panel with the radical
democratic representative ayanna presley
the ringo of the squad and she
described and lamented her terrible
white privilege
forty percent of americans with
disabilities report that
they have real challenges voting in
person and so in states where there
haven't been
kind of no excuse absentee voting or
whether
you know hasn't been the introduction of
early voting yet you know
it still isn't um kind of easy
fair or equal for many americans to vote
i think it's really important that my
children understand that and i think
it's particularly important that they
understand that
as white children of privilege because i
want them to erode that privilege
throughout their lives to ensure more
people are
enfranchised and that equality isn't
just an ideal
so none of that is true and no parent
has ever said
i want my child not to have any
privileges yes i want my child to be
disadvantaged and chelsea clinton's not
saying that either
what she's doing is tying this idea of
universal mail-in ballots which is a way
the democrats are trying to steal the
election
with this idea of privilege you know
we've basically
got to destroy all of our election
security in the name of
fairness and equality and of course it's
all lies it's lies about mail-in ballots
it's lies about race it's lies about her
family
this is not about ending a system of
white privilege
this is about preserving a system of
liberal
elite privilege and on this show we will
attempt to tear down
that system of oppression i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
oh we are dismantling oppression today
my friends
my favorite question or comment rather
from joe yesterday if joe biden
goes to ancestry.com i don't think he
would find anything
after all he's been running for
president since pangaea existed that is
true and great reference to pangaea
very few people list the uh
global continent in their political
jokes but well done
uh also have to thank our friends over
at legacy box
speaking of family histories and
maintaining those traditions
i love legacy box so legacy box very
simple concept
you've got old photos you got old video
tapes you got
you got old slides you got all this old
physical material and you know sometimes
they fade over time sometimes they get
lost if you move they could
they could get misplaced or they could
be destroyed
and then you lose all of those memories
so what legacy box does is it takes all
that stuff
and it digitally preserves them on a
thumb drive dvd or on the cloud
legacy box helps bring new life to your
old media
by unlocking all of those old trapped
family memories
i love it i just used it for photos of a
family member who had died and i'd lost
a number of the photos that i'd had and
was extremely upset about that so i sent
the ones that were remaining to legacy
bucks
it's great you can access them anytime
process is super easy
start to finish you pack and send them
they digitize everything
and then they keep you up to date with
regular email updates throughout the
whole process
go to legacy box right now legacybox.com
knowles to get 50 off your first order
during the labor day sale that is order
today
send in when you are ready this
exclusive offer will not last for very
long
i really love these guys great service
legacybox.com will say 50
while supplies last
lots of talk about privilege everyone
especially
racial privilege that's especially white
privilege
that's what the left is getting everyone
to focus on right now so that you ignore
the actual privilege that is being hung
over you
a professor at the university of north
carolina chapel hill school of
information and library science just
tweeted out the other day this is a blue
check mark on twitter and she's
a professor she said that all white
people
have been deputized to kill us us being
black people
that professor's name is tracy mcmillan
cotton she's in the uh
she's a professor at this uh university
and she was
tweeting this in response to some
republicans supporting kyle rittenhouse
who was that kid who was attacked by
antifa
and who fired back and stopped the felon
and the pedophile and the armed guy
from killing him all white people
have been deputized to kill us i think
if you've been watching the blm
riots for the past four or five months
now you would believe that you would
believe that there is this scourge in
america
this epidemic not of a virus but of
white people racist whites just
slaughtering innocent black people right
you've probably heard that
demi lovato who i'm told is a singer
says that she hates her skin color
because she shares her skin color with
all these killers she said quote
all i knew was that i hated that i
shared the same skin color as the people
accused
of committing heinous crimes against a
mod arbory brianna taylor george floyd
and many many other black lives
capital b now we're capitalizing these
colors
so is this true should one feel this
intense white
guilt this guilt that white people are
slaughtering black people all over the
place
the statistics don't bear that out and
we're going to get to statistics a
little bit later in the show
because i i made a provocative point
yesterday on statistics
and some people were upset about it but
we will get to that but i will name
these statistics now
in 2019 do you know how many black
people were murdered in the united
states
2925
total number of black people in the
united states murdered do you know how
many of those were murdered by white
people
234
234 out of 2925
do you know how many of those black
people who were murdered were murdered
by other black people
2600 2600 out of 2925
that means that eight percent of black
people murdered last year
were murdered by white people 89
of black people murdered last year were
murdered by black people
but you would not know that statistic
you would not know that fact
if you were watching the mainstream
media or listening
to our political leaders or listening to
the activists because for some reason
those statistics
don't seem to matter they're so
interested in science these
are so interested in looking into the
precise scientific analysis
of white supremacy and all this sort of
thing
but those statistics don't seem to
matter you're given a very different
picture
we'll get to why as i said a little bit
later this doesn't just even stop at the
political level
this goes all the way up to the
religious level even the most
traditional institution in the christian
west the catholic church
the cult of white guilt has infiltrated
the catholic church
a parishioner i suppose recorded this
homily i don't know if you could call it
a homily from a priest at saint xavier
catholic church
in new york city who is now engaging in
the liturgy of wokeness
do you support racial justice equity and
compassion in
in human relations do you affirm that
white privilege is unfair and harmful to
those who have it and to those who do
not
yes do you affirm that why privilege and
the culture of white supremacy must be
dismantled where it is present
yes do you support racial equity justice
and liberation for every person
yes do you affirm the inherent worth and
dignity of every person
yes therefore from this day forward
will you strive to understand more
deeply the injustice and suffering white
privilege and white supremacy cause
yes will you commit to help transform
our
church culture to one that is actively
engaged in seeking racial justice and
equity for all
for everyone yes will you renew and
honor this pledge daily knowing that our
church and our community
our nation and our world will be better
places
because of our efforts yes
i can't say i've ever heard that system
of vows in a catholic church what this
is of course i mean
for individual aspects of that nobody
would disagree yeah be nice to people
don't be mean to people be be a good
person don't be a bad person right
but what this is really describing
is a a new and separate and replacement
theology for christianity this is now
the theology
of wokeness you're replacing what may
appear to be one's baptismal vows
with the with now being baptized into
the the waters
of wokeness saying that there are these
things white supremacy white privilege
haven't haven't seen those anywhere i
don't know exactly what
what the priest means by this i know
that we have
one matter of legal racial
discrimination in our country there's
only one matter
where it is legal to discriminate by
race that is called affirmative action
it benefits black and hispanic
applicants for jobs it disadvantages
white and asian applicants for jobs
that's it show me the other legal white
supremacy
or any legal white supremacy for that
matter show me the legal racial
discrimination other than affirmative
action
where is it nowhere it doesn't exist
so what is this priest talking about
he has fallen prey to
the same thing that i think a lot of our
country has which is
a distraction it's not even
that all this talk about white supremacy
or white privilege or whatever all the
racial division
that seems to be conveniently ginned up
every four years
is it it's not even that it's in good
faith
it's not even that you know maybe some
people who have
good intentions are mistaken it is a
distraction
to distract you from a genuine system of
privilege
and uh inequity in this country which is
liberal elite privilege liberal elite
privilege which manifests itself in the
media
in politics in the universities in
education for that matter in hollywood
and big tech
there is a liberal established
apparatus that plays by a completely
different set of rules
than you and i play to and it doesn't
matter what color
our skin is it doesn't matter what what
matters is this political distinction
here
which we can get to a little bit later
in the show i'll give you a real example
of privilege here think about how crazy
it is
that blm a mark in a validly marxist
organization
that seeks to destroy the nuclear family
has now taken a foothold
in a catholic church in new york think
about
how sick the society must have become
that a catholic parish in new york
is spouting the marxist idiocy
of black lives matter but
the people who are ginning up this kind
of tension are very good at it
only occasionally do they get caught
like nancy pelosi we talked about this
yesterday nancy pelosi
big supporter of the lockdown saying
donald trump is killing people
because he didn't totally lock down the
country nancy pelosi gets caught on a
camera on a security camera
walking into a hair salon that she wants
closed
without a mask that she wants everybody
to wear because she's nancy pelosi she
can do whatever she wants
you can't because you're not a member of
the elite liberal establishment but she
certainly can't so she gets called out
for it what does she do does she take
responsibility no
she blames the salon owner we'll get to
that in one second first though got to
thank our friends
over at ring there's a thousand reasons
why protecting
your home matters to you ring has
security products
for every single corner of your home
inside and out best of all
you can see it all with one simple app
that means you can be in your bedroom
that means you can be at the office that
means you can be on the beach
i love it just makes me feel safe
especially these days people are feeling
a little bit on edge oh alisa's a very
good shot
but i still want to make sure i can feel
safe if someone steps by
if something's going on ring lets you
know it's peace of mind
anytime knowing that your home is
protected protect your whole home
with ring alarm one thing i love about i
give this away as a housewarming gift to
my friends
and my favorite part of this is it's not
very expensive so i seem like i'm giving
this
incredibly expensive gift it's so useful
it really
changes people's homes sense of security
but then i don't have to pay a lot of
money for it which is really great get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit
right now ring.com
knowles it comes with rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to start your ring
experience plus
free two-day shipping now is the time to
do it i've been telling you about ring
for a long time go get it ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles
so pelosi gets caught pelosi gets caught
breaking all the rules that she says she
believes in because
she wants her hair cut makes sense a lot
of other democratic politicians have
done this bill de blasio did this in new
york lori lightfoot did this
in chicago so
nancy pelosi finally holds a press
conference to
address this problem what does she do
she goes on the attack
i take responsibility for trusting the
word of a neighborhood salon that i've
been to
over the years many times and
that when they said what we're able to
accommodate people one person at a time
and that we can set up that time i
trusted that
as it turns out it was a setup so i take
responsibility
for falling for a setup and that's all
i'm going to say
on that i take responsibility that the
salon owner was such a jerk this is this
typical example which i've noticed my
liberal friends tend to do more than the
conservatives where they say
look i'm really sorry if you got really
offended by something
say no you can't be sorry if i feel
something you've got to be sorry for
something that you did
and what nancy pelosi did is she
violated the rules that she said for
everybody else because it was convenient
to her
now she's a brilliant politician you
have to hand it to her
and she probably gave the most politic
response to this you could imagine
which is she feigned ignorance of the
law
now that's no excuse of course but
particularly now
it's implausible you're telling me that
the single most important political
issue
that you nancy pelosi have been a part
of constructing
you didn't know about you didn't know
that the hair salons are closed
how did you how could you not know that
no of course she knew that but then she
said no
it was a little gray area because i
didn't know if one person comes in
if then it could be open and it's almost
a plausible excuse until you realize
wait a second
hair salons are by definition one on one
right
a hair one hair stylist per one customer
so if if the hair salons
were not you know were open for one
customer at a time
then the hair salons would just be open
but they're not so the owner
of this hair salon erika kaios i don't
know if i'm pronouncing that correctly
went on tucker carlson of course of
course tucker got her on that night
and explained that she did not set up
nancy pelosi she had called the stylist
and
or her assistant did and made the
appointment so
the appointment was already booked so
there's no way i could have set that up
and i've had a camera system in there
for five years i mean i didn't
go in there and turn cameras on as soon
as she walked in to set her up
so that's absolutely false but erica
what about
pelosi's excuses are you telling me that
pelosi's excuses don't make any sense
as a hairstylist i see clients
one-on-one
so that would mean i would be open
right yes of course it would of course
that's what that means
the left always has to be the victim the
left
always has to play the victim card here
so
nancy pelosi institutes these draconian
stupid rules
nancy pelosi and the democratic party
broadly institutes these stupid lockdown
rules that haven't done any good and
have done a lot of harm
to put it bluntly and then
she breaks them because it's not
convenient for her and then when she
gets caught what does she do
she pretends that she is the victim from
the victim of a setup even if it were a
setup by the way
and what do we mean by setup we mean
let's say the salon owner doesn't like
nancy pelosi
and wants to show that she's been
violating her own rules
that's still pelosi's fault what's the
setup
the setup is the setup is basically hey
nancy pelosi
do you want to violate all your own
stupid rules she goes yeah absolutely
say okay well i caught you on tape
saying absolutely because that's a setup
no it's just exposing what you're doing
what you've been doing it's exposing
your own character what you think about
these things
but but you see this if nancy pelosi can
pretend to be the victim
over breaking her own lockdown rules
then the left can feign victimhood
over anything and they do
they feign victimhood over affirmative
action
the left which instituted affirmative
action now also claims that affirmative
action
is racist and leads to a racist country
because now some people think that if
you you know if a black person
is in a job that perhaps affirmative
action helped and that isn't that's an
ugly assumption to have
well clarence thomas wrote a whole
nother whole book about this but he
wrote about this extensively in one of
his books
which is that he hated the stigma of
affirmative action because he knew that
he was
intelligent enough and more intelligent
than than most of his classmates but
because of the stigma of affirmative
action
that took away from his accomplishment
of course
but you can't have it both ways for the
promoters of affirmative action
they want to have the advantages of
affirmative action but not
the stigma associated with it clarence
thomas points out that's not possible
the left they don't even buy rather what
they are selling
they don't even believe what they are
saying obviously nancy pelosi with her
haircut
also also members of the mainstream
media who know that the mainstream media
is vicious and dishonest there was a
hidden tape just came out
of chris cuomo speaking to donald
trump's now
imprisoned former attorney michael cohen
that turn code
chris cuomo apparently is friends with
trump's old attorney
he describes how the media are just a
bunch of animals
you know i'm always careful when i talk
to media
you know right do you know how many
phone calls i've gotten from people at
abc who say that reporters
are calling and lying about things they
heard about me to try to get stories
about me when i was at abc
guys calling and saying i heard he was
the charlie rose of abc used to invite
women to the hotel and open his uh
bathroom do i look like the kind of guy
who's got to do that
sure why not
that says that he forced one woman to
have sex i just want to know if you've
ever heard anything like that
there is no woman right there is none
other so here's the problem women who do
work there saying oh yeah you know
some of these men and naming me with
other guys you know we bumped into each
other once in the
elevator and he put his hand on my
shoulder and he made me really
uncomfortable
i mean what the it's it's it's a problem
and now you're so
careful with the media always i've
always told you the media is not your
friend
no the media is not your friend now what
is significant about that conversation
one
it's kind of funny that chris cormor is
getting advice from trump's former
attorney that they're all
they all have attacked for many years
but chris cuomo here
is pointing out one there's no
journalistic integrity out there and the
media are just trying to push
an agenda and not even he trusts them
but he's a member of the mainstream
media
there's a big difference between the
mainstream media and alternative media
sources we do need some kind of
journalism right we do need some kind of
political commentary but
what we know is there's a big difference
between say this podcast or other
concert or conservative alternative
media
and cnn one difference is
usually we get better ratings in
alternative conservative media
but cnn is part of the established media
right most of cnn's ratings
come from airports it's just on at
airport tvs
because that is considered to be
authoritative and very serious news
and chris cuomo goes out there every
night and says yes we're very serious
news and yet
in his heart he knows that the media are
full of it they're not objective in any
way they're not even interested in the
truth
they're liars and their rats
his brother andrew cuomo governor of new
york
is now threatening donald trump andrew
cuomo in new york says this about the
president
he better have an army if he thinks he's
going to walk down the street in new
york new yorkers don't want to have
anything to do with him
he can't have enough bodyguards to walk
through new york city people don't want
to have anything to do with him so this
is a direct threat from a democratic
governor
and the democratic governor who handled
coronavirus worse than any governor in
the country
against the president of the united
states can you imagine if a republican
governor said this about barack obama
he would be put on trial he'd be sent to
the hague he would be called a racist
and a vicious monster and a terrible
person he'd they'd there would be calls
for him to be kicked out of office
with andrew cuomo saying this directly
threatening the life of the president
saying he better not come here he's
going to need an army because otherwise
he's going to get killed
what happens to him nothing now is that
a racial privilege
no i don't think it's a racial i don't
think the italians get any particular
privilege
do i think that the fact that if the
situation were flipped and was barack
obama's president any republican
governor do i think that's a black
privilege no i don't think it's that
i don't think it's i think we're looking
at privilege all the wrong way
i don't think it's a matter of racial
privilege at all
i think it is a matter of political
privilege
liberal establishment elite privilege
which totally exists
and it's why this story is going to get
totally buried
it's going to get totally buried as the
democrats
as the liberal establishment tries to
steal this election and make no mistake
they are actively attempting to steal
this election now you you might not know
that if you watch the mainstream media
because the the primary method right now
that they're using to steal this
election
through fraud is this universal mail-in
ballot
issue and the mail-in ballots are being
are highly unreliable they can be
harvested
they first of all just often don't get
there in the mail right there have been
experiments done
where three percent of of mail-in
ballots don't even end up
in in the hands of the recipients forget
about where they came from first
so they're trying to steal that but
they're trying to tell you there's no
such thing as mail-in ballot fraud
there's no such thing as trying to steal
elections when the democrats are doing
it
when republicans are looking like
they're in a good position
all of a sudden all we hear about is
election fraud we're told that if you
have to present an id to prove you are
who you are
that you're committing election fraud
and stealing an election
but now that the democrats are trying to
harvest ballots from senior citizen
homes
all of a sudden no such thing wolf
blitzer at cnn
took this liberal position tried to
smack down attorney general bill barr
the honey badger
who was bringing up all of these issues
bill barr
wouldn't let him have it he explained in
excellent detail the nature of
voter fraud in the united states the
bipartisan commission chaired by jimmy
carter
and james baker said back in 2009
that mail-in voting is fraught
with the risk of fraud and coercion
since then and
until this administration you know well
i've approved it let me talk yeah please
uh and since this since that time there
have been
in the newspapers in networks academic
studies
saying it is open to fraud and coercion
the only time the narrative changed is
after this administration came in
but elections that have been held with
mail have found substantial fraud and
coercion
for example we indicted someone in texas
seventeen hundred ballots collected
he made from people who had could vote
he made them out
and voted for the person he wanted to
okay because that kind of thing happens
with mail and everyone
of course everyone knows it and look at
how the narrative changes that's the key
there he says
what about this commission uh chaired by
jimmy carter and and jim baker
that's that found that there is
substantial fraud in mail and
you were all talking about that until
the day before yesterday the minute he
gets into that
all of a sudden wolf blitzer tries to
cut him off billboard won't let him do
he says no
i'm not going to let you do this today
i'm going to explain to you how it works
so then wolf blitzer moves on to the
next democratic talking point first is
there's no fraud whatsoever in the mail
the next talking point is okay
and they always say this whenever you
cite any case of actual voter fraud
they'll say okay that's one individual
case but there's no
widespread problem bill barr shuts that
down too
there are individuals cases but as far
as widespread fraud
we haven't seen that since we have we
haven't had the kind of widespread use
of mail-in ballots that's being proposed
we've had absentee ballots from people
who request them
from a specific address now what we're
talking about
is mailing them to everyone on the voter
list when everyone knows those voter
lists are inaccurate
people who should get them don't get
them which is what has been one of the
major complaints in states that have
tried this
in in municipal elections and uh
people who get them are not the right
people they're people who
have replaced the occup the previous
occupant and they can make them out and
sometimes multiple ballots come to the
same address
with a whole generate several
generations of occupants
do you think that's a way to run a vote
well the only thing i'm saying is that
so far we haven't seen widespread fraud
but so far we haven't tried it
it's like wolf blitzer has nothing left
it's like he's that non-player character
meme he's like he's a robot just beep
boop he's got
the pre-programmed line which is well
we've seen it on an individual level but
we haven't seen it on a widespread level
billboard gives a great answer he says
right we've never tried it on a
widespread level
we've no we've never tried this
universal mail-in thing we've done
absentee
which is not only different to in degree
but it's
different in kind from what's being
proposed because with absentee you have
to specifically request it to a specific
address here we're just going to mail
them out to wherever you remember how
that cat that's been dead for 20 years
got an absentee ballot a couple of
months ago
there's a call i forget which state it
was in a couple came on they said yeah
cat who's been dead for 20 years got an
absentee ballot
and i just think i don't think that dead
cats should vote and that's
that sort of thing is happening people
who have moved out of homes they'll get
the ballot to the old address so
billboard completely
strikes that down wolf blitzer's got
nothing left he says yeah but it just
seems individual not widespread but
says right i just explained to you why
that is we've never tried widespread
what's going to happen then wolf blitzer
keeps pushing so bill barr makes the
biggest point of all which is
we're in uncharted territory and we're
playing with fire
the point is that a lot of us there are
several states that only have
mail-in voting including a republican
this is playing with fire
this is playing with fire we're very
closely divided country here
and if people have to have confidence in
the results of the election and the
legitimacy of the government
and people trying to change the rules to
this to this methodology which
as a matter of logic is very open to
fraud and coercion
is reckless and dangerous and people are
playing with fire
of course he's absolutely right and of
course he strikes this down
and the liberal elite privilege is not
having to answer that for now the
several years they've been trying to
push this sort of thing but
unfortunately they made the mistake of
inviting the honey badger on cnn and he
wouldn't let them get away with it
some good news in the presidential front
uh trump right now
is leading joe biden by two points in
north carolina 49-47
this according to a poll released on
tuesday by east carolina university
polls and other places are tightening up
and you know i don't pay a ton of
attention to polls
poll public opinion polls are a
relatively recent invention of the
social sciences
which i'm highly skeptical of anyway
polls famously
were pretty wrong in 2016. some people
still try to defend the polls in 2016
but the fact is all of the meta-analysis
of all these polls showed hillary at a
99
chance of of winning and then when she
lost they said no they weren't wrong
it's just that
the one percent turned out to be true
and that this is the problem with
not just polls let's go back to
something else that's a little bit older
but it's still a very recent invention
statistics lies damned lies and
statistics i got in trouble yesterday on
the show
because i made a point that
conservatives generally speaking
should shun statistics because
statistics
were created very recently by and for
the liberal progressive establishment
what has evolved into
the liberal progressive establishment
even using the word evolved kind of
plays into that
that narrative now people were shocked
they said michael what are you talking
about we need statistics
no we don't we i mean we can use
statistics when they help us but we've
got to be very very careful about
statistics
because i think some people when they
heard me say that conflated statistics
with facts that's that's how
deeply embedded this problem has become
but statistics are not facts
statistics in many ways are the opposite
of facts what does statistics mean
it's a new concept relatively new
concept it refers to
the state data for the state
and as statism has come into its current
form
statistics have taken on a very
important role the word statistics comes
from the
late 18th century german word
statistique
i don't know how to pronounce i don't
have a great german accent yeah yeah
statistic
late 18th century this is derived from
the new latin statisticum
collegium council of state and the
italian word statista
right statist
this word statistic in german first
introduced by
gottfried achenwall in 1749
designated the analysis of data about
the state
specifically the science of the state
and around this time you see the advent
of what you would call political science
the social sciences
economics sociology political science
which is a new concept as opposed to
political philosophy
the idea here being that there is a
science
not only to biology well even biology is
a relatively new one
a science to physics for instance or a
science
to precise things that we can measure
under a microscope
that's there's not just that kind of
science but there's also a science to
society
there's also a science to history
there's a science to human affairs and
politics and that
you can measure once you understand the
science you can know with scientific
certainty
how society should be governed you can
know how history will progress
you can know the end of history you can
know the right side of history
you can know all of these sorts of
things by applying the methods of
physical science to society and the
questions that were
previously explored by philosophy
and by by the
philosophy of politics rather than a
science of politics so what what social
science does
is it comes in and says okay we've got
to separate
the administration of society from
politics politics is usually
just all people arguing and trying to
persuade one another and deciding how we
want to live
yeah that's too messy so what we've got
to do is separate the way that society
is actually governed
by the administrative bureaucracies from
politics so ironically what happens is
that everything gets politicized
my cup of coffee gets politicized my
choice in clothing my choice in sneakers
gets politicized everything is
politicized except for politics the
political questions are actually taken
away
and decided by these headless
bureaucracies
and how do the bureaucracies create
these policies
they use data given to them by another
aspect of the liberal establishment
which is the university
and what does the university give you
statistics so they just write they say
we
you've heard this the whole coronavirus
pandemic this is actually the best time
to think about this point we've been
told look
i don't want to hear from politicians
meaning i don't want to hear from our
duly elected representatives
meaning i don't want to hear from how
citizens want to govern themselves
i just want to be governed by science
and data
the trouble is the idea that there is a
science of society
is complete bs it is a lie
used by liberals or progressives or
leftists whatever words you want
to take political power away from you
grab it for themselves and never have it
threatened because they say well we're
just
we're just deferring to science we need
the green new deal we need to
redistribute
trillions of dollars to our favored
groups away from
the groups that we don't like why do we
have to do that oh science
yeah we need to lock you all in your
homes forever and we need to have the
federal reserve print up lots and lots
of money
and we need to borrow trillions of
dollars and we need to give it out to
favored groups why oh because of
science um
show me the science i don't see the work
there and the
the raw material that goes in and is
used to justify
these kinds of policies is statistics
okay but statistics can be abused i'm
not saying that you can't
count certain things and have data of
course you can do that but statistics
can be abused i'll give you an example
let's say uh 60 of america likes
chocolate ice cream 40 likes vanilla ice
cream
you can come in and say look 60 of
america likes chocolate ice cream that's
the majority of america
we just need to mandate chocolate ice
cream for everybody that's statistics
that's just science
but you can eat make the exact same
argument say wow
40 of america likes vanilla ice cream oh
my gosh 40
of america gosh that that means we need
to have an abundance of vanilla ice
cream available
now this is kind of a silly example who
knows what the
applicability of that would be it is
only to
say that the statistics
the numbers can be used to make any
number of arguments and we know that i
mean we've seen this
threat not just the coronavirus but even
in just recent decades we've seen how
statistics
are always used sometimes to make
opposing arguments
and i'm just giving an example where we
can actually rely on
60 like this 40 like this 60 do this 40
do this sometimes it's not even that
clear and by the way where do these
statistics come from usually it's
they come from some scientific paper
social scientific paper so
not actually a scientific paper and the
statistics have been compiled
they've been put into models that are
obviously very fraught
that's why you might have noticed the
models did not work out during this
coronavirus pandemic they often don't
the models about global warming have not
turned out to be true the models about
any number of these things don't turn
out to be true because as dr fauci said
the models are only good as the
statistics that you put into them
but who puts in the statistics that some
grad student who never has their work
checked who i don't know maybe they have
some weird methodologies maybe they
don't even
it's a it's a way of manipulating you
and edmund burke the great conservative
philosopher said
the age of chivalry is gone that of
sophisters economists and calculators
has succeeded it and the glory of europe
is extinguished forever
we cannot be those economists officers
and calculators
we shouldn't be these egghead
statisticians manipulating data and
pretending that political
authentically political questions really
should just be decided
by a couple of eggheads and lab coats
who pretend that they know
the entire science of of history and the
politics
and of society that is not only
profoundly
anti-conservative not only does that
feed this kind of liberal established
elite
privilege it totally undercuts the
concept
of self-government and the political
traditions that we
so cherish it's my last defense of
throwing statistics out the window
i head on over to the michael noshow
youtube channel subscribe we appreciate
it also you get the daily
wire app on apple tv and roku so you can
watch us on the big screen
head on over we got a lot more with the
mailbag coming up we'll be right back
all right first question from gabby just
heard your story about michelle obama
and the ice cream shop
so this story in case you missed it a
couple days ago was that michelle obama
went into an ice cream shop when she was
first lady
and someone cut her in line and that's
how she showed that there was such a
thing as white supremacy
and she's so oppressed and everyone
should feel bad for michelle obama
that's the story
when as first lady did michelle obama
ever just go out to an ice cream shop
without the secret service in tow i'd
love to hear your thoughts yeah the
story is obviously preposterous even if
she had even if she told the secret
service to wait around the corner which
probably they would not have done anyway
she's michelle obama she's one of the
most famous women in the world
so the situation that she is presenting
as
she's waiting in a shop and then someone
cuts her in line and then she says hey
stop cutting me in line and then the
person
goes away and doesn't look at her and
doesn't pay proper obesity
to the the wonderful one michelle obama
may have been the case that this other
person walked into the shop
you're not quite sure where the line is
who's waiting who's already put in their
order who's
who's just now off to the side waiting
to get their ice cream and then michelle
obama was very rude to him
and then this person was was intimidated
because you're talking to the first lady
of the united states
and was quiet two different ways to read
that situation which one do you think is
more likely
do we think that michelle obama one of
the most popular women in america
is really just a victim of horrible
oppression do we think america
america which elected her husband
president twice
for some reason elected her president
utterly unqualified to be president but
they they elected him twice
it's just because of how horrible and
racist and bigoted it is i don't think
so
from mitch hey michael i remember
learning about how louisiana
and the great state of texas were the
last two states in the union to change
the legal drinking age to 21.
this was only after the federal
government threatened to cut federal
funding of some programs highways i
believe
since these liberal states and cities
are shirking any and all sense of
responsibility in an effort
to signify their wokeness could the
federal government
employ a similar tactic we've already
seen the mayor of minneapolis ask
president trump for a federal bailout
from the riots
which the president quickly shot down
but couldn't he take it a step further
i do not wish to signify intent to cause
harm or demolish the way of life in
those areas
but wouldn't a simple ultimatum of clean
your mess up or prepare to lose whatever
benefit the city is receiving
uh thanks for your time hail to the
exalted dr fauci peace be upon him
i suppose they could they are actually
attempting this in certain places
they're saying we're going to cut
federal funding to cities for various
programs
if you don't clean up your cities the
question is is it going to have any
teeth
when you look at something like trying
to change the drinking age or other
programs the federal government has
tried to push on the states
they often succeeded during periods of
some
bipartisan consensus and that does not
exist at all
now i mean anything that trump says or
does the democrats will oppose
trump could support giving lollipops to
orphans and the democrats would say
that's a terrible thing
no candy for the kids so it would seem
difficult now because
you know the federal government could
threaten it but
the the at least the elected power of
the federal government
could change at any given time and
actually what this
does even this kind of partisan division
is in power is the topic we've been
talking about all day which is this
the the liberal elite establishment
which governs
through the bureaucracy which shapes
public opinion which then
permits these changes shapes public
opinion through the mainstream media and
through hollywood
and through the universities that
establishment is just going to keep on
governing and doing whatever it wants
and maybe sometimes republicans get
elected but
it's not a fair fight it's not an
elected democrat against an elected
republican
it's an elected republican against the
entire apparatus
of the state from cameron hi michael
i've recently been struggling with
solipsism
i've suffered from ocd since i was 12
and because of this i'm now hyper
focused on this concept
life seems less colorful and i'm
starting to withdraw from friends and
family
i was wondering if you had any ideas on
how to cope disprove this idea from an
agnostic standpoint
as everything i've read on the matter
says it's impossible to argue against
thank you in advance
for taking the time to answer my
question my pleasure so solipsism for
those who don't know
is the belief that it is not possible to
know that the external world exists
meaning uh it it's that
i cannot know for certain that anything
other than my own consciousness
exists and sometimes this is
just used as a synonym for egotism
or narcissism or you know self-obsession
and i in some ways it is right you're
you're just so enthralled of yourself
i i once bandied this solipsistic idea
around when
first when the concept was introduced to
me when i was a teenager
i started thinking about it i said oh
gosh you're right i guess i can't
prove that the outside world exists
but so what then this reminds me of
these questions of
does free will exist well the only way
that i could prove that free will exists
is by freely using my rational faculties
that i can rely upon objectively
or to to at least perceive objective
reality and then
come to a conclusion but that would beg
the question because i would
and by beg the question that doesn't
mean to ask a question that means to
assume my own conclusion
because by doing that i'm implicitly
asserting that
free will does exist because i'm freely
choosing to use my rational faculties
to grapple with the question of free
will to come to a conclusion so i'm
already doing that
so i can't answer that my answer to
people who ask
who say to me that free will does not
exist is to punch them in the face
now look i'm a fiery but mostly peaceful
podcaster but i would punch them in the
face
and say ow michael stop punching me in
the face i'd say
i'm not punching you in the face i have
absolutely no control
there's no moral culpability at all i'm
you know we're just predetermined bags
of atoms and
and as the blood starts pouring down on
their face and my knuckles i'll take a
towel maybe i'll say look it's not a
wish
i wish that i could stop but i don't
even exist in any
proper sense of that term because i have
no free will
and then when my friend is a bloodied
mangled mess he will have gotten the
point
you will have gotten the point it's also
interesting that you ask me you say
i want you to prove this to me from an
agnostic point of view
so not only are you denying that i in
the external world exist but you're
tying my hands behind my back
you're saying i have to prove something
from the standpoint of not knowing
something
agnostic means not to know so that's
obviously impossible that's a game
that's set up to fail
i would take another angle here rather
than trying to prove with certainty
that the external world exists
uh i would
look look at the history of the concept
of solipsism
where it comes from uh i would look at
the history of
self-described solipsists and then i
would look more broadly at our
philosophical tradition
it seems to me much clearer or much
much harder to argue that the external
world does not exist
than that the external world or rather
yes that the external world does not
exist then the external world
does exist it seems to me that the
burden of proof is on the one who denies
all that we can perceive and then form
concepts of through our rational
faculties
now of course you can't i mean the way
the question is set up you you couldn't
prove it
but what where does that leave you i
suppose that could leave you in a place
where
you can't rely on anything and every
every single thing is an illusion
and then what then we might as well sit
quietly in the corner
but assuming you're not going to do that
assuming that that seems
irrational in as much as you can trust
your own rational faculties
i would do it i would move on and see
for just from the
practical effects of it uh what gives
you
a a view and an and an action of life
that is uh that that
conduces to human flourishing just try
that out
leave the philosophical theorizing aside
for a second and look to the practical
aspects of life see what that does
from kevin morning mr knowles from the
great welfare state of minnesota i have
been told by a retired government worker
that the reason the governments like
abortions is because it is a smaller
investment
than having another person added to
welfare and keeps the lower class
population in check
which to me is disgusting but at the
same time also gives me a reason why
none of the conservatives in office ever
actually do anything is it would cascade
down a route
that would guarantee that they would
wouldn't get voted back in
which if that's the case is also
disgusting that this decision
would put their career before the life
of the defenseless please let me know
your thoughts on this as i respect your
knowledge and opinion well the first
part's true in the second part i think
is not true
the first part we we know for a fact the
founder of planned parenthood margaret
sanger said
she wanted to get rid of poor people and
deficient people and people who can't
take care of themselves because that
would be a drain on
well it would be a drain on the state in
part and margaret sanger is writing at a
time when
the state had a a really central role in
basically every
ideology and it was you know
this was at a time when you saw the rise
of not only liberalism which existed but
but fascism and communism all of which
are totally concerned with
the state so that part's obviously true
i don't think that conservatives
are afraid of fixing abortion for
instance
because they think they're not going to
get voted back in
you know it's it's not that the rich
people vote for republicans and the poor
people vote for democrats actually it's
kind of the opposite right
wall street tends to go for the
democrats these bill
most billionaires in america vote
democrat the liberal established elite
votes democrat and actually it's
deplorable irredeemable people who tend
to vote republican
republican party at various times but
especially right now it's much more of a
working-class party
than the democratic party so i don't
think that's the case i think the reason
republicans are hesitant to do anything
on abortion is because they raise a lot
of money on it that's that's actually
why i think that a lot of elected
republicans
don't really care one is probably
because they don't care about it much
themselves and then they realize there's
a great fundraising benefit to the
pro-life issue
which is disgusting too but that's
that's a different reason
than they worry about not getting
reelected all right last question from
tim
what is this this involves a note they
gave me a note on white privilege okay
this was posted on facebook by a former
homeschooler whose child was just
just started at st paul's catholic high
school in bristol connecticut overall
it's a decent school however this
handout was given
out in a school-wide assembly yesterday
i'm curious to hear your thoughts on
work politics infiltrating even private
catholic schools
this is on white privilege oh there's a
little a number of bullet points or 26
bullet points i'll just go through a few
so i guess it's explaining what white
privilege is i can if i wish arranged to
be in the company of people of my race
most of the time
i think i think a lot of people can do
that you can see you see
self-segregation in neighborhoods and
social circles so everybody can do that
if they wish
i can be sure that my neighbors in a
location that i move to will be neutral
or pleasant to me
i can't assure that and not just because
i'm a little swarthy or something
i i think that i mean there are blm
signs in every yard in every
city or suburb in all of america so i
think it's not a racial issue
but i can't assure that when i move into
a neighborhood people will be pleasant
to me the minute they find out my
politics they hate my guts
because if you're a conservative in
america today you are
counter-cultural you're you are you have
a politics of dissent
from what we've been talking about all
show this liberal establishment so
so that actually that backs up my thesis
right that's
that the real privilege is kind of
liberal elite privilege not a racial
question
i can turn on the television or open the
front page of a newspaper and see people
of my race widely represented
there's a ton of entertainment for black
people and hispanic people in this
right you've got tv stations you've got
magazines you've got outlets you've got
websites that's crazy if i want to i can
be pretty sure finding a publisher for
this piece on white privilege
well you can because it's liberal but
it's not because of your race
first of all getting books published is
hard but
you could get this drivel published
anywhere couldn't you right
it is it's published in every liberal
outlet on the internet
okay blah blah blah posters cards oh
here we go oh here's one this
actually ties right in to the top of the
show number 22 i can take a job with an
affirmative action employer
without having co-workers on the job
suspect that i got it because of my race
that's the privilege so even affirmative
action is
actually a way to disadvantage white and
asian people
by law and they make all these arguments
for it so but that is it right it's to
racially discriminate against white
nation people and even that now is taken
as a
symptom of white privilege because if
you do get a job and you're whiter asian
you can at least be said to think that
you got what you deserve except
the whole ideology of white privilege
says that nothing you have is something
that you deserve
total incoherent drivel it's very sad
that a catholic school would do that
catholic schools are supposed to be more
conservative than the insanity at the
public schools but the rot runs very
deep
runs very very deep it's not just nancy
pelosi and hillary clinton it's not just
a couple elected politicians
it runs all the way down through the
media through hollywood through
technology through the schools
through the catholic schools through the
catholic church through
and when i say the catholic church i
just mean that as an example of the most
conservative institution
it goes throughout all of the protestant
denominations
all over the west that is a deeply
embedded privilege how do we
reform that system of oppression we will
leave that to next week i'm michael
knowles it's the michael knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. you know the matte wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen